though my me I was just reversing the
polarity of the neutron flow so before
we get into this I got a little bit of
business first
shout out to my patron Nick hopper who
not only is a very cool person
supporting me on patreon which you can
do as well apparently he also appeared
in Doctor Who no really he was in
partners in crime he was one of the
people liked and shown on mass when the
whole thing with the adipose was going
on like people I go uh
he was this guy thanks Nick
classic who review time and this will be
the first one as selected by my patreon
supporters they got to vote on what what
I was gonna do and it ended up being
planet of the spiders the last story to
feature the great jon pertwee as the
third doctor
it's his regeneration story I should
probably pause here right now and point
out I will be talking about spoilers you
should know that and I honestly didn't
know what to expect going into this the
last couple of classic who stories that
I've done I had certain expectations I
went into deadly assassin with
expectations based on the fact that most
things I had read or heard from people
who had seen it they really liked it so
that set those expectations when I dealt
with the twin dilemma I had expectations
based off the fact that a lot of people
cited is one of the worst things Doctor
Who ever did I don't really hear about
planet of the spiders like one way or
the other it's it just doesn't seem to
be a story that comes up in conversation
very much unless you're talking
specifically about regeneration stories
and even then it's not one people dwell
on like people will much rather talk
about Lagavulin or wargames
or caves of Androzani definitely nobody
seems to really want to talk about
planet of the spiders and I didn't know
what to make of that my suspicion was it
probably means it's just very may
because if it was bad people would want
to talk about it the same way you know
they people like to talk about stuff
like the twin dilemma
so I honestly had no expectations and
even having now seen it I haven't like
stopped to do research to find out what
the general feel from fandom is on this
but it's not great and unfortunately
it's made worse by the fact that it is
Jon Pertwee's last outing as the doctor
it's a pretty boilerplate Doctor Who
story of the time you know there's
spiders coming from the future to earth
and they're working with this kind of
cult ish thing almost kind of sort of
not really a cult but like they've
connected with these people who were at
a spiritual retreat and the doctor has
to stop a potential invasion the spiders
also happen to be really big with
mind-control powers and they can sort of
latch on to people's backs and then make
people shoot lasers and all that weird
kind of wonderful quirky can't be sci-fi
stuff very pulpy and and there's nothing
inherently wrong with that as a story
for this era but it you you hear that in
like okay so it's yeah the the the title
pretty much says it all I'm basically
mostly gonna be nitpicking this thing so
if you're somebody who likes the story
I'm gonna apologize in advance but there
are a few things that go on here that
stand out as really good examples of
things that I mean when I criticized
some of the jank eNOS of the production
values of classic who that people say I
just don't get it I'm being too hard on
a low budget for and I feel like I can
better explain with some examples here
then possibly anywhere else because I I
really don't think I hold dr. whose
budgetary restrictions against it as
much as some people seem to believe that
I do so let me explain let's take the
spiders themselves as far as on a TV
budget you know decent-sized spider
thing they look fine they're not great
they were never gonna look great but
they look fine actually the great ones
not bad at all mainly because they put
it in a terrific settings oh I mean prop
so that one but where they fall down is
not on boy these spiders don't look real
where they fall down is the conception
of the design which is they do nothing
to distinguish these spiders they have a
crap-ton of identical spiders and all
they had to do just to freshen it up a
little bit was I don't know put a black
widow thing on the back of the Queen
just cuz there's like there's specific
spiders with agendas and personalities
and good luck telling them apart at all
even on site because even the voices I
just I checked this because I found
myself going did they just have the same
person do all the voices for the spiders
no there's actually three credited
performers for that but they did they
did the exact same thing to the voice so
they they sound incredibly similar so
you can't tell them apart on site you
can't tell them apart by voice alone and
it's just not possible to get invested
with the fact that one of them kind of
has her own agenda and maybes going
against the Queen when you can't tell
the freakin things apart and that's what
I mean when I criticize the design of
this
I'm not criticizing the build of the
spider the build of the spider is fine
but there was no thought put into
finding a way to just quickly visually
distinguish them the only way you could
tell the Queen was Queen was to kind of
put her on a purple pillow and she's not
even there the whole time later on they
have a different spider there and that's
what kind of stuff that drives me nuts
another good example is the green screen
there's some bad green screen in here
and I'm not holding the fact that the
show can afford to do good green screen
but shouldn't they know that the green
screen is bad that they should write to
avoid using it as much as possible
that's not me saying never set it on an
alien world or whatever but there's a
bunch of parts like especially when the
when Sarah Jane Smith and Lofton first
get transported to the other planet it's
a green screen effect I don't know why
forego
life of me I cannot possibly think why
liked it I know it looks cheap but stick
them in a frigging quarry and then pull
back to a model shot the way you
normally do because this green screen
looks terrible and you should know it
looks terrible and there's no reason to
use it there so that's what I that's
really what I'm getting at when I
criticize the production value not the
limitations but the fact that they don't
work within it they keep trying to build
stuff that they can't realize or they
build something that would have taken
virtually no effort or additional
thought to just make a little bit better
make a little bit more distinctive and
they just don't do it or sometimes they
don't do it and when they don't that
frustrates me so now that I've gone off
on that little rant let's get off the
production values the whole story is
kind of stretched a bit thin there was
no reason for this to be six parts I
mean as far as I I'm assuming they had a
block how many episodes they respected
to fill during a season so maybe there
was in terms of that kind of obligation
but just narrative Lee speaking
there's no justification for making this
six parts the second episode especially
it is this prolong pointless chase where
first Laughton runs away and he steals
the doctor's car so the doctor gets in a
different car or some folks get in a
different car and the doctor chases him
and his gyrocopter but then Lofton
abandons the car and he's like hiding
and then Lofton steals the gyrocopter
and then the doctor chases him and his
car was in his car that he just got back
from London which it now turns out can
also fly and then lufton's in a boat and
the doctors chasing him anon and a
hovercraft okay first of all this is the
second episode so there's no tension to
this maybe Lofton is gonna get away but
the plot hasn't even kicked in yet this
is this is literal wheel spinning the
wheels of these cars and of this
gyrocopter are just spinning and going
nowhere and it's it's like this weird
James Bond's James bond-esque divergence
that would have worked if they had the
budget to do a chase decently but they
don't and they should know that like
that episode two was painful and there's
also something like
here's something that bothers me but I'm
gonna let pass because of the time even
though I'm not even sure how okay it was
at the time but it was it this was kind
of a practice that one arm which is
these um these very British people
passing themselves off that's as
Tibetans that who that's that's a little
uncomfortable I like I I can't a new
consciousness not point that out but at
the same time I'm not really gonna knock
the episode for that cuz like I said it
was kind of standard practice for the
time so it's just kind of what they did
and before anyone tries to argue with me
oh he wasn't actually a Tibetan he was a
Time Lord and the projection was a red
light they were convincingly passing
themselves off as Tibetans until it was
revealed this guy was a Time Lord the
doctor thought he was spoke to him in
his name native language respecting the
customs of that country it doesn't
matter whether he really was or not we
are meant to believe that people
believed he was which means he's
supposed to convincingly look like that
and he doesn't okay I forgot that Sarah
Jane Smith could be very up-and-down for
me from story to story
I love the the character overall but
there are some times some writers some
stories they they don't know what to do
with her besides have her scream for the
doctor and she does a lot of that in
this episode and it's unfortunate
especially considering I loved her debut
episode I loved her introduction in the
time warrior and I liked her on a lot of
the other stories Elisabeth Sladen is
wonderful in this character but
sometimes she just gets paired with
writers who very clearly don't want to
have her do anything other than scream
and get rescued so there's there's a bit
more of that going on than I would care
for I haven't talked about the man
himself yet John Pertwee who is I mean
he's good he's good in this part he's
always been good in this part I think
the highlight by far is like at the very
end the moments before there were
generation itself when he's weak and on
the floor and he's talking to Sarah Jane
and you know just these rooms
tear sarah-jane you know I had I had to
face my fears it was more important than
you know living with with these
questions and these things so that those
were nice moments those were touching
moments those were well-played moments
and they're moments that work in
isolation completely separate from the
story and have nothing to do with it
which I also don't know how much to
knock the episode for because the
classic series when it came to
regenerations
usually the regeneration stories weren't
about the fact that the doctor was gonna
regenerate which is kind of been more
the thing with most of new who that's
very much what was going on in the time
of the doctor that's definitely what was
going on in the second half of the end
of time and in the first half to to a
certain sentence absolutely what was
going on in twice upon a time classic
series didn't really do that they tended
to just have an adventure that the
doctor happened to not live through this
well I mean you know he regenerated and
all of that and so this fits in that as
far as it goes but it still feels like a
really weak send-off and I know they
were in an onion and viewable position
because you know the long-term plan had
been for him to regenerate because of a
plan enacted by the master by Roger
Delgado who unfortunately had passed
away before you know this whole last
season even began shooting he was in a
car accident so they just didn't have
him and without the master to like truly
pull that together and I'm just I I
think it probably would have been
amazing but without that it's just kind
of oh so this is just the adventure that
he didn't survive oh okay yeah I feel
like he himself is really the main thing
that I can praise the the performances
aren't bad actually as much even though
you know I took some time mocking some
of the casting but the the acting is
actually all fine some of the writing I
don't really like but the acting is all
fine even even from the spiders they're
fine and the weird sort of slightly you
know regrets
humans on the planet they're fine
the guy who plays Tommy is final though
hey have no idea where that character is
there like at all I understand his plot
function because he gets the crystal
away from Lofton but like that's a weird
choice and the fact that he gets smarter
doesn't mean anything it doesn't impact
the plot in any meaningful way
whatsoever he could have remained just
as stupid and just been infatuated with
Sarah Jane and that would have been
plenty of motivation enough for him to
go against you know the ones that he
went against so I don't understand I
don't understand why he was there in the
first place for anything other than plot
logistics and I really don't understand
why they went having him go you know all
flowers for algernon out of nowhere so I
don't I don't know what the point of him
was but the guy played him fine um
actually I'd even give props to him he
was equally can he was pretty convincing
for somebody who was smarter but like
didn't necessarily have genuine
knowledge just higher intelligence so
he's he's reading you know books of a
higher level but he's still having
trouble because he never learned what
these words mean he can now read them
and he can understand the ideas if he
knew what the words meant um and you
know so that's actually even a really
kind of cool moment and it's a concept
that I think actually would have a fair
amount of mileage in it but doesn't have
anything to do with the story and it's
just more time killing it's more wheel
spinning it's more we have to fill six
episodes for some reason yeah it's just
kind of a bummer the the Third Doctor's
Ryan it kind of goes he goes out on a
bit of a damp squib and and then and
that's a shame so I don't know what I'll
get back to third doctor again III
definitely want to try and find
something that is more you know highly
praised again it will be voted on by my
patreon supporters so they'll get the
final say but I might I might try and
limit the options to stuff that is
supposed to be genuinely good or at
least that I've heard is because I I can
be contrarian when it comes to this
stuff sometimes I don't mean to be I
really don't but we'll see so yeah I
think that's about all I've got really
plenty of the spiders it's
as a story completely unto itself it's
okay it's not particularly well-executed
in the visual Department aside from the
great one in that throw you know what
there is a there is one other thing
because I got onto the great one again
but that throwing room and it's good a
visual as it is and that is a genuinely
good visual and that actually is also
occasion where the green screen for the
doctor doesn't even look that bad I have
a real issue with villain plans that
basically defeat themselves
I kind of hate that I hate when the end
of the story it basically turns out oh
you know if we just had stayed home and
not bothered trying to stop them this
whole problem would have fixed itself I
could have just stayed at home and had a
cup of a cup of tea I kind of hate that
because it makes the heroes pointless
and ineffectual
and not need to be there like to my way
of thinking the only story that I can
think of off the top my head with that
actually worked where the the the
villains plan actually causes their own
defeat when it succeeds is Raiders of
the Lost Ark and the only reason that
works is because the the initial idea of
maybe no one should be finding this at
all maybe it's meant to be buried maybe
nobody should see what's inside this
thing gets laid throughout the film so
it's an undercurrent that gets paid off
as opposed to oh no you you don't want
to do that and then they do it like oh
well like oh you shoulda listened to me
now you're defeated like just huh it's
irritating like out of fundamental level
I just hate that so yeah I think I do I
have to land on the side but I didn't
really like this and I'm and I'm
frustrated by that cuz I like Jon
Pertwee in this part but between how
much action stuff they give him to do to
the point that he himself easy even says
at one point this is getting monotonous
and I actually said out loud yes it is
you please stop so it's it's just it it
tries to be a celebration of him by
having the chase and showing off the
gadgets and like two different cards on
the gyrocopter and and having them do
tons of the Venetian Venusian Aikido or
whatever it was but it none of its in
service of the plot it all feels crammed
in and it all feels like they do the one
thing for a whole stretch of time like
that second episode is nothing but
chases to show off the gadgets and then
it was episode o4 I think where it was
basically like a long series of him just
flipping guys left and right and that
was the episode where he's like this is
getting monotonous and like yeah here it
is so I just feel like without the
ability to pay off the master in any
kind of finality at the time they just
they just kind of shrugged it went yeah
guess we're doing spiders and they just
crammed in all this stuff that was very
much embodiments of his era but it's not
flowing it's not gelling nothing's
feeding on each other it's just here's a
chunk of an element from his time here's
another chunk of an element from his
time there's one other moment that I did
really really really really like though
which was him saying basically saying
that he gets the TARDIS to the planet
and the TARDIS picks the specific
landing spot because it knows better
than he does and of course he's
referring to it as a she and the
Brigadier is like you're speaking about
it as if it's alive and the doctor and
that would that wonderful Jon Pertwee
smile at am i yes I suppose I am well
god I love that smile and I don't know
if that's the first time that there was
implied sentient to the TARDIS I haven't
seen enough of the stuff between like
the start of Doctor Who in this episode
to know whether or not that's the first
time I think it might be though and
that's a great moment and there are good
moments there are good visuals there are
good bits and pieces and performances
but man it doesn't add up too much so
that's planet of the spiders so did you
ever see this what were your thoughts on
it whatever they are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it
to all that stuff you know like
subscribe support I'm on patreon I got
Twitter I got a podcast links for all
that stuff down in the description and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]